Struggling with Tax Dance skills in Modern Warfare 3.
Don't worry,
I've the fastest way for you to complete this challenge
in as little as one game. First off,
you're going to need to know how to get into Tax Dance
as it is a new addition to the call of duty series.
Simply just press down on the D pad whilst aiming
down site. The fastest way to complete this challenge.
It's simple,
just jump into hardcore mode
as you will kill your enemies in one,
and that's pretty much regardless of the range.
But you want to be avoiding the larger maps
in favour of the small to medium sized ones.
But to actually hit your shots,
you're going to want to make sure you've got the right
attachments that reduce your tax dance spread.
These are often found on the barrel,
under barrel
and stock attachments.
But most importantly,
you will want to stick a laser on
that is active when aiming down sight
so you can see where you are aiming.
As in hardcore
there just are no cross as
making it really difficult to accurately aim.
Don't forget to like
and subscribe for more no nonsense guides!